hey guys my name is Jess it is the 16th
off every and this is your daily catch
up of everything that's been going on in
gaming let's get going first up the
Ghost Recon wildlands open beta is
bearing down on us and here's what
you'll want to know about that Ubisoft
has announced that the open beta will
run from februari 23 to faerie 27 on ps4
xbox one and pc the open beta includes
all the same content as the closed beta
as well as additional content in the
form of a province called a monte York
which I definitely pronounced wrong
Ubisoft explained set in the Bolivian
altiplano region the province contains
heavily defended strongholds where the
Santa Blanca cartel trains some of its
toughest soldiers if you participate in
both betas you'll receive access to the
unidad conspiracy which includes 3
exclusive missions accessible upon the
game's release in other word land use
the pc specs and requirements have
landed you'll need at least a core i5
2400 s or FX 4320 along with 6 gigabytes
of ram and a gtx 660 or HD 7870 and
that's just to run the game at low
presets at 720p recommended specs call
for an i7 3770 or FX 8350 8 gigabytes of
ram and a gtx 970 or r9 290x you can
check out the full list of specs in our
story on games but next up digital
foundry is reporting that sniper elite
force ps4 pro frame rate doubles that of
the Xbox one digital foundry claims that
the unlocked frame rate on ps4 pro tends
to hang around 45 to 55 FPS while sniper
elite four is capped at 30fps on Xbox
one the report claims that the Xbox one
frequently dips below that mark even
dropping into the high teens in
particularly demanding scenes on the ps4
the frame rate is mostly contained
within the 30 to 40 FPS mark the ps4 ps4
pro and Xbox one all render at 1080p
eight and generally look the same
according to digital foundry finally
Activision has announced when the crash
bandicoot remaster trilogy's will arrive
earlier today acted teased a big
announcement for the well-loved
franchise on twitter it was later
revealed that crash bandicoot insane
trilogy will arrive on jun 30 and
polygon is reporting that it'll cost
forty bucks the trilogy includes the
first three games in the franchise Crash
Bandicoot crash bandicoot cortex strikes
back and crash bandicoot warped the ps4
game is being made by activision spike
arias visions although the originals
were developed by naughty dog the
remasters use the original level
geometry with updated gameplay a unified
checkpoint and save system and well as a
unified menu system and time trials that
is everything i have for you today head
to gain sweat for stories on Mass Effect
Andromeda and hearthstone and be sure to
click that subscribe button so you don't
miss our top five stories of the week
tomorrow I will see you then